nir pour détruire et causé des dommages
considérables
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 8 juillet le
vaccin 100% efficace contre le
confinement déclarations d'olivier
ferrand alors que l'exécutif continue de
consulter avant son conseil de défense
de lundi en jeu la vaccination
obligatoire du personnel de santé face à
l'inquiétude une quatrième vague jean
castex en déplacement à blois n'a pas
écarté l'utilité pour certaines
personnes de recevoir une troisième dose
de vaccin un rush highgate chez les
médias américains c'est hautcoeur gelson
jaune anis part de la très conservatrice
chaîne fox news qui crée la polémique
le présentateur accuse en effet la nes l
agence nationale de la sécurité d'avoir
voulu l'évincer de l'antenne au motif
qu'il avait tenté d'obtenir une
interview de vladimir poutine consensus
trouvé en nouvelle calédonie après cinq
mois de vacances gouvernementales
louis ma peau devient le premier
indépendantiste kanak à la tête de
l'exécutif collégiale locale une
première depuis le début du processus de
décolonisation de l'accord de nouméa et
ce avant l'organisation du troisième et
dernier référendum sur l'indépendance de
l'archipel prévue le 12 décembre
vous n'avez vraiment
[Musique]
suite des consultations avant un énième
conseil de défense sanitaire lundi
prochain à l'elysée l'exécutif prend
cette fois le pouls des élus locaux au
sujet de la vaccination obligatoire pour
le corps médical
leitmotiv du gouvernement vacciner à
tout prix pour éviter une quatrième
vague ont fait le point avec mona modèle
or depuis matignon bonsoir ona c'était
donc au tour de jean castex de lancer
une consultation
[Applaudissements]
mona manifestement un petit problème de
son alors se mariant delta qui est
inquiétant va-t-il nous gâcher le
déconfinement at on les moyens de notre
liberté y at il une menace sur les
vacances c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage ce soir avec nous pour en
parler pierre tattevin infectiologues
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses du chu de rennes
philippe froguel chercheur généticien
vous est également professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et de
l'université lille 2 et enfin l'ex fis
poulain notre éditorialiste bonsoir à
tous les trois messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur l'antenne d'arte
et france on tentera de retrouver un mot
n'a peut-être au milieu de ce duplex at
on n'a pas réussi à joindre tout à
l'heure pour nous faire un état des
lieux de cette pression qu'eux mais le
gouvernement sur les français pour
qu'ils aillent se faire vacciner mais
dans le spectre un évidemment d'une
quatrième vague alors chaque jour cette
pression semble s'accentuer d'un cran le
gouvernement a clairement un discours
alarmiste alors que l'on vient tout
juste de lever les dernières
restrictions la situation est-elle
vraiment préoccupante pierre tattevin
la plainte est de 20,6 dément alors on
va se tourner vers un philippe froguel
en espérant que lui nous entende
philippe froguel décidément c'est petit
c'est une farce ce soir voilà merci on
vous entend
bon philippe froguel je vais me tourner
vers vous allez nous sauver je crois de
se re de ce mauvais pas où je vais finir
par faire mon nom c'est d'être numéro de
claquettes à l'antenne ça fait tellement
d'années je veux le faire ça va être
pour ce soir je pense en cette fin
d'année
est ce que c'est une situation aussi
alarmante
philippe froguel pour l'instant n'est
pas alarmant en france même si l
augmentation en nombre de cas mais j'ai
vu tout à l'heure ce qui se passait aux
pays bas avec une augmentation de 500%
du nombre des personnes contaminées en
une semaine et si c'est la même chose
qui nous arrive en france dans quelques
semaines on risque d'atteindre une
situation avec plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de cas car par jour à et on
espère que ça sera surtout des jeunes
qui n'ont pas besoin d'être hospitalisée
mais hélas comme l'a dit le gouvernement
est encore 20 % des plus de 80 ans qui
sont pas vaccinés et une bonne partie
des plus de 50 ans en plus on a vu dans
les chairs aujourd'hui que une dose ne
suffisait pas et qu' il fallait
absolument avoir deux doses pour être
protégés contre le variant delta donc il
ya de quoi être pas paniquer comme
malheur d'être le gouvernement veut être
inquiète de tout faire mais vraiment
tout faire pour ralentir au maximum la
progression de cette nouvelle épidémie
pierre tattevin je me retourne vers vous
un discours donc alarmistes du du
gouvernement alors que les discothèques
par exemple sont supposés ouvrir demain
par mois on a on a perdu définitivement
pierre
ta devin on va écouter olivier vers ans
et gabriel atteint qui était au centre
de vaccination de nanterre pour une
petite séance de pédagogie avant de vous
faire réagir alexis poulain écouter le
ministre de la santé surtout mon message
était de leur dire que le vaccin il les
protège à 95% des formes graves
par contre je les protège à 100% du
confinement c'est dire que si tout le
monde est vaccinée on n'aura plus à se
poser la question de savoir si nos
restaurants nos bars à nos commerces et
des universités peuvent rester ouverte
dans la durée on n'aura plus à se poser
la question de savoir si on doit ou non
porter le masque à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur on en aura fini avec le
virus on retrouvera évidemment à l'excès
poulain clairement les ministres en
service commandé en faveur de la
vaccination il faut dire que le risque
est gros et le risque politique pour
emmanuel macron sûr sur cette séquence
voit évidemment mails macron pensait
qu'avec la campagne de vaccination
s'accélérant et atteignant sa vitesse de
croisière
le virus était derrière nous et puis
arrive le variant les variants delta
epsilon et puis je ne sais pas quelle
lettre grecque va arriver après et on se
rend compte que l'efficacité du vaccin
certes là mais moindres est que il ya
une course de vitesse qui est finalement
engagée alors même qu'on ne sait pas si
ça va fonctionner sur un prochain
mariage donc la promesse qui était celle
finalement dû déconfinement de la
liberté retrouvée avec d'un côté la
vaccination de l'autre on garde tout de
même les gestes barrière est en train de
s'éloigner un peu partout y compris en
france
on est en train nous en france d'ouvrir
les discothèques alors que les chiffres
arrivent en disant qu'il ya eu 200
contamination le week-end dernier deux
dans un pays européen qui avait ouvert
cette discothèque est donc la question
est qui veut ouvrir qu'il veut fermer et
puis on a la grande bretagne à côté de
nous un pays largement vaccinés ou le
delta a pris le dessus et où boris
johnson qui fait finalement et bien ça
suffit on va arrêter d'enfermer les gens
on va arrêter avec tout ça même les
masses car ce sera la discrétion de
chacun il faut que la vie reprenne avec
celui du rsa alors c'est un pari à
prendre est ce que la vie peut continuer
avec ce virus
ou est ce que c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire qui attend l'angleterre là
c'est un choix qui est critiqué par
certains scientifiques
du côté britannique mais c'est un choix
qui est fait et puis en inde on a vu
aussi que le delta est passée par là et
puis les contenus
sion ont décru donc on n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment fonctionne finalement
ce coronavirus on pense que la
vaccination est l'alpha et l'oméga sans
jeu de mots de la solution mais la
solution ne restent pas que ça il ya
aussi les gestes barrières les masquer
le fait aussi d'être vigilants par
rapport à ça et de voir comment
fonctionne ce virus aujourd'hui on ne
sait toujours pas on al impression qu on
tâtonne malgré à cette vaccination alors
maintenant jean castex nous dit que
c'est de non pas une ni deux mais trois
doses pour que ça fonctionne
est ce que ce sera après une dose par
trimestre une dose par an tout ça est
vraiment finalement ça n'aide pas parce
que aujourd'hui que veulent les
gouvernants c'est que le monde reparte
l'économie reparte surtout parce que
toutes les prédictions qui sont dans le
dans les tuyaux les 5% de croissance de
bruno le maire si jamais l'épidémie
arrivait et qu'il fallait reconfirmer ou
retrouver des mesures coercitives
alors là patatras ça ne marchera pas et
puis d'un autre côté vous avez des
populations qui en ont ras-le-bol et qui
ne veulent plus de mesures liberticides
qui veulent retrouver leur liberté
quoi qu'il en coûte puisqu'on nous parle
de quoi qu'il en coûte systématiquement
et un moment où on commence à se dire
mais quand est ce qu'on va en voir la
fin de ce virus et on a l'impression que
c'est une histoire sans fin
philippe froguel clairement à ce qu'on
allait les moyens de cette liberté
aujourd'hui alexis poulain faisait
référence au royaume uni on a vu ces
images ans ça nous a pas échappé au web
les fière de ses supporters britanniques
aiment à ces délais les uns sur les
autres on en pense qu'on veut mais c'est
vrai quand en plein qu'ovide ça peut
faire bizarre dans le même temps il ya
ce
test concert se concertaient 7 à paris
avec masques alors c'était le 29 mai
avant le delta où la conclusion c'est
pas de sur risque de contamination
clairement aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut
se permettre encore ces attroupements
cette réouverture des des discothèques
en réalité la science ne peux rien vous
dire aujourd'hui puisque tout est un
prêt était imprévisible
sauf que le delta allait venir moi je
fais partie de ceux qui début juin on
dit aux yeux vairons attention aux
relances et la vaccination parce que
début juillet s'avéraient augmenté et je
vous garantis que le gouvernement
n'était pas sur cette ligne il était sur
une ligne tout va bien et il faut qu'on
se référer pour les élections la
maintenance et tout va mal et donc
personne ne sait si on sera sur la pente
des pays bas ou sur la pente anglaise et
là ce qu'est ce qui ferait la très très
grande différence peut-être c'est les
personnes de plus de 50 ans parce que le
confinement n'est parfait il a jamais
été fait en france pour une seule raison
qui est de l éviter l'engorgement des
hôpitaux d'autant que les hôpitaux sont
pas engorger je ne pense pas qu'il
raison à nouvelles de faire le
confinement maintenant de faire que les
choses soient respectées dans les
restaurants j'ai encore vu à midi à
lille s'était pas respecté le fait que
c'est peut-être pas la meilleure chose à
faire le monde d'ouvrir les boîtes de
nuit aujourd'hui ça c'est sûr mais
surtout surtout surtout il faut que les
gens se vacciner comprennent qu'il faut
trois semaines pour qu'un vaccin soit
efficace et moi j'ai entendu sur des
radios aujourd'hui des télés et les gens
qui disaient ah mais je me faire
vacciner pour partir en vacances à
barcelone où je vais faire la fête
non hélas je suis vraiment de le dire il
faut trois semaines est en réalité il
faut deux doses de vaccin pour que ce
soit efficace
on a un mois de retard
le variant delta par rapport aux anglais
mais lassant mais deux mois de retard
sur la vaccination
c'est sa maman qui inquiète en tout cas
gabriel apte à lui clairement fait
planer la menace un de restriction à
nouveau je vous propose de l'écouter
si on veut ne pas avoir à reprendre des
restrictions des mesures hyper
contraignantes
il faut qu'on atteigne l'immunité
collective et donc se vacciner c'est un
petit pas pour soi mais c'est un grand
pas pour l'immunité
tiens ta demain on vous a retrouvé avec
bonheur quand vous voyez cette pression
monte un lot gouvernement qui souffle le
chaud et le froid qui dit que l'était
peut être gâché dans le même temps on se
déconfite totalement ça vous inspire
quoi vous en tant qu' en tant que
médecin il est désolé pour les soucis
connexion j'ai entendu tout donné j'ai
entendu ce que disait philippe rogué jus
tout à fait d'accord un effectivement on
a notre chance de ne pas subir une trop
grosse vague à la rentrée ça va être le
mieux vacciner possible et de ne pas
faire de folies pendant cet été et donc
je pense qu'on a du répit de on espère
quelques semaines c'est le moment pour
améliorer notre couverture vaccinale et
éviter le pire on vient entendre avec
six poulains gabriela talent clairement
il ya ça défaut de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire il ya cette petite musique
qui ressemblerait à un gentil chantage
en gros c'est soit on vous rend confie
non on vous prive de votre liberté ou
soit vous allez passer à la piqûre
complètement
c'est vraiment là la politique du nudge
celle qui pousse les gens à faire
quelque chose sans les obliger à mais en
rendant tout contraignant
ce passeport vaccinale c'est pas
sanitaire que certains voudraient
obligatoire même pour aller au
restaurant ou n'importe où dans les
lieux de la vie publique et puis le fait
de dire qu'il y aura finalement pour les
non vaccinés plein de barrières pour
plein de choses
la question de la vaccination
obligatoire des soignants bien sûr qui
est sur la table tout ça qui pose
question parce qu'on attende de savoir
si effectivement les vaccins vont
fonctionner avec les nouveaux variants
on voit bien alors certes il fonctionne
sur les cas graves sur l'hospitalisation
visiblement il ya une décorrélation
entre les cas de contamination et les
gens qui se retrouvent à l'hôpital donc
ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais qu'en
sera-t-il de la suite et combien de
piqûres vont être nécessaires pour
l'immunité
donc aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il ya
une poussée aussi du gouvernement avec
attal avec cette poussée sur les jeunes
de vouloir vacciner les jeunes de 12 à
18 ans
c'est eux qui doivent se faire vacciner
parce qu' ils ont en tête bien sûr la
rentrée scolaire en septembre si cette
rentrée n'est pas préparés alors nous
aurons des supercluster et de nouveaux
événements contaminants dans les écoles
c'est exactement les erreurs qui ont été
faites en 2020 même si elles n'ont pas
été qualifiées d' erreur à l'époque
encore monsieur castex avant d'être
premier ministre était monsieur
déconfinement et bien les cabinets de
conseil qui l'entouraient avait dit -
les i c'est bon on peut on peut tout à
fait vrai les écoles aujourd'hui on voit
bien que la préparation est en amont et
qui vient évidemment le temps de la
vaccination
ce temps là c'est un décalage
effectivement entre première deuxième
dose et efficacité c'est à moi qu'il
faut compter le mois d'août est
aujourd'hui donc on pousse la population
française à se vacciner pour s'assurer
évidemment une couverture à partir de
septembre sans être sûr qu'à nouveau
variant ne pourrait pas arriver et
rebattre les cartes puisque c'est le cas
pour des pays qui se pensait à l'abri
qui avait mis le virus derrière eux eh
bien non c'est plus compliqué que ça
avec 7
cette façon de faire du coronavirus qui
reste encore à voir est effectivement
aujourd'hui la clé c'est le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation
qu'ovide dans les hôpitaux
s'il reste en deçà de ce qu'on a connu
alors il n'y a pas de raison de confiner
ou de continuer avec des mesures
liberticides
avec le danger bien sûr de ces mesures
contraignantes de diviser la population
française de faire une une population
vip qui seraient les vaccinés et puis
une population de renégats qui seraient
les non vaccinés qui auraient droit à
rien ça c'est dangereux je crois qu'il
ya une rupture du conte du pacte
républicain dans cette pente glissante
qui est en train d'être martelé
systématiquement pour inciter les gens à
se vacciner
philippe rogué d'une question peut-être
naïve mais à partir du moment où les
plus fragiles sont vaccinés
et les populations qui ne sont pas à
risque ne le sont pas pourquoi ne pas
laisser faire tout simplement et créer
ainsi une immunité collective alors ça
ça a été essayée certaine façon la
dernière notamment en septembre et on a
bien vu ce qui s'était passé
c'est à dire que progressivement les
jeunes se sont contaminées et ont fini
par contaminer leurs parents leurs
grands parents les soirs des personnes
plus âgées
vous me direz la bonne et moi c'est la
différence c'est qu'aujourd'hui ces
personnes là les plus âgés seront
vaccinés oui mais il ya toujours un hic
et l'oeil ya deux hivers le premier
c'est qui encore 20 % des plus de 80 ans
qui sont pas vaccinés et une forte
proportion des plus de 50 ans et
deuxièmement à partir de 80 ans il ya un
papier qui est sorti la semaine dernière
qu'ils disaient et je pense que c'est
que lui aussi pour la grippe et d'autres
vaccinations que les vaccinations marché
certaines personnes âgées - chez
d'autres et donc c'est pour ça qu'ils il
faudrait que les soignants notamment des
ehpad soit vaccinée pour éviter de
ramener le virus à des gens qui sont
peut-être pas très très bien protégé
dans les ehpad clairement pierre
tattevin que peu annonce emmanuel macron
début de semaine en tout cas vous en
tant que médecin qu'est ce que vous
espérez de la part du président de la
république aujourd'hui je crois que
l'obligation vaccinale pour tous
personnels de santé tous les gens qui
sont au contact de personnes à risques
est vraiment importante j'entendais ce
que disait votre éditorialistes il ya
deux choses à mon avis qu'il faut revoir
un peu c'est d'abord on sait qu'ils
marchent ces vaccins c'est à dire que
même dans les pays où ces revenus parce
que c'est invariant plus contagieux les
gens vaccinés ont été protégés ce qui
ensuite de doses du vaccin ont fait
beaucoup moins de variants delta que les
autres et puis la deuxième chose
on sait que si on laisse trop circuler
le virus on va avoir de plus en plus de
variants ça c'est vrai il va être de
plus en plus fort c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être très bien vacciné c'est plus
on sera mieux vacciner à l'échelle d'une
population - y aura-t-il prédation du
virus est moins de chance d'avoir encore
à nouveau vers y en ait pilotes ce que
vous voulez après le delta la protection
c'est le maximum
philippe froguel aujourd'hui l'exécutif
qui déconseille aux français de
réserver des vacances en espagne au
portugal est ce que c'est c'est justifié
ce type de conseils pas très sympathique
d'ailleurs pour les espagnols et les
portugais qui comptait un petit peu se
refaire avec le tourisme
bon d'abord la situation au portugal et
en espagne servette situations demain
dans le sud de la france où là où les
gens vont aller en vacances ou loups aux
dents dans les plages de l'atlantique
donc on a simplement quelques semaines
d' avance mais hélas je crains qu'on va
avoir la même situation au bientôt bon
c'est pas très sympathique c'est clair
et c'est un peu protectionnistes et je
pense pas que les gens qui ont déjà
réservé leur voler leur hôtel avant ne
pas partir à barcelone ou à au portugal
donc c'est ce que j'appellerais une
déclaration à déclaratives verbales mais
qui dès qu'ils montrent pas grand chose
alexis poulain à dix mois de l'élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron on imagine marche sur
des oeufs
c'est sa candidature qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui oui enfin c'est un des
sujets évidemment si cette crise
sanitaire n'est pas gérée à la fin de
l'année ça va être très compliqué pour
lui de se représenter d'avoir un bilan à
défendre puisque il pensait en avoir
fini puis là il a eu quelques décisions
controversées
quand il a choisi de ne pas confiné de
continuer avec plus de cent mille morts
à l'époque il était vivement critiquée
puis en disant finalement il avait
peut-être pas tort la façon dont il a
géré cette crise aussi de manière
extrêmement personnelle avec ses
conseils de défense qu'il présidait les
conseils de dépenses reviennent avec
bien sûr tout l'opacité qui vont avec le
fait qu'ils décident entouré servent de
conseiller mais c'est lui qui va
cristalliser bien sûr les critiques
puisqu'il a voulu être au premier rang
de cette gestion de la crise sanitaire
alors ils gardent bien sûr olivier
ferrand au ministre de la santé et jean
castex jusqu'à la fin de cette crise
sanitaire parce que ça n'aurait aucun
sens de s'en séparer en plein en pleine
crise donc on va voir et évidemment ça
peut être compliqué puis il ya le rêve
pas les bilans les réformes qu'il veut
remettre sur la table réforme de
l'assurance-chômage réforme des
retraites
qui là aussi sont extrêmement contestée
donc cette une fin de mandat difficile
sachant qu'en plus en réalité le mandat
est déjà terminé l'action ne peut pas se
faire sur les quelques mois qui reste
c'est du déclaratif également de dire
que l'action durera jusqu'à la dernière
minute c'est pour se mettre en scène et
dire qu'il aura tout fait pour essayer
de faire passer des réformes
s'il se déclare à nouveau candidat pour
sa réélection
ça c'est ce qu'on verra dans la suite
des opérations mais clairement si la
crise sanitaire n'est pas géré je vois
pas comment il pourrait se représenter
devant les français merci en tout cas à
tous les 3 alexis pour la pierre
tattevin on est heureux finalement
d'avoir pu interviewer quelques minutes
philippe froguel également merci à tous
les trois et on va retrouver un mot
namouh de enor là ou encore la liaison
était rétabli puisque c'est la suite des
consultations un énième conseil de
défense sanitaire lundi prochain mona
c'était donc au tour de jean castex de
lancer une consultation mais exactement
stéphanie c'est au tour du premier
ministre de recueillir finalement les
avis des associations d'élus concernant
est d'abord la vaccination obligatoire
pour les soignants et puis l'extension
du pass sanitaire avec en ligne de mire
un projet de loi à ce sujet puisqu'il
faut savoir que dans les ehpad 57% des
soignants sont vaccinés et 64% sont
vaccinés dans les hôpitaux mais ce n'est
pas assez selon olivier ferrand depuis
plusieurs jours le gouvernement se
prépare doucement à face à la montée des
cas de contamination force est de
constater que le variant delta gagne du
terrain puisque selon santé publique
43,5 pour cent des cas de contamination
en france sont de ce variant et 55 % en
ile-de-france sont du variant delta
également de son côté est le
gouvernement réfléchit toujours donc à
des mécanismes d'incitation à la
vaccination a pour la population
française les
motif le sait il marche sur des oeufs et
il ne veut pas brusquer les soignants
qui ont été durement éprouvées depuis la
crise sanitaire mais il veut faire
preuve de fair mais fermeté en même
temps à savoir également il ya ce
conseil de défense sanitaire
exceptionnel qui aura lieu le 12 juillet
et toutes ces questions seront abordées
et mona que faut-il attendre de ce
conseil sanitaire de défense
[Applaudissements]
je vous disais depuis quelques jours le
gouvernement cherche des mécanismes
d'incitation pour pousser lé français
massivement aller se faire vacciner
plusieurs mesures seraient envisagées
d'abord à la vaccination obligatoire
pour plusieurs fonctions l extension du
passani terre le déboursement des tests
pcr le renforcement de l'isolément et
encore et encore ou enfin plutôt lé
restrictions aux frontières c'est en
tout cas au président de la république
emmanuel macron deux tranchées merci mme
oda amont dès lors pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de l'hôtel de
matignon à paris est toujours en france
un des établissements ne nuiront francs
à eux demain près 16 mois de fermeture
une réouverture sous conditions strictes
plus d'explications avec estelle farges
depuis le quartier de pigalle à paris où
de nombreuses discothèques sont
concentrés rendez vous sur la piste de
danse c'est avec ces mots que le
ministre délégué chargé des pme annoncé
sur twitter le 21 juin dernier la
réouverture des boîtes de nuit un rendez
vous que certains établissements n'ont
pas envie d'honorer selon le syndicat
national des discothèques et lieux de
loisirs est cette boîte de nuit sur 10
devraient rester fermés ce 9 juillet
conséquence du très contraignant
protocole sanitaire demandé aux
établissements
il y a tout d'abord les jauges de
remplissage les boîtes de nuit ne
pourront pas dépasser 75 % de leur
capacité d'accueil habituelle
et puis le pass sanitaires pour pouvoir
accéder à la piste de danse il faudra
être en possession d'un test pcr datant
de moins de 48 heures ou d'un test
antigénique prouvant l'absence de
contamination ou alors d'une preuve de
vaccination complète ou encore d'un
certificat de rétablissement datant de
plus de 15 jours mais de moins de six
mois sur la question du passé ni terre
le syndicat national des discothèques
pointe des incohérences au sein d'un
même type de métier aujourd'hui le pass
sanitaire est obligatoire dans les
établissements pouvant accueillir plus
de 1000 personnes en france seuls 40
boîtes de nuit ont cette capacité
d'accueil il dénonce aussi des
inégalités chez avec notamment les bars
dansant non soumis à ce protocole
sanitaire pour le snd ll il s'agit tout
simplement de concurrence déloyale
certains préfèrent donc rester portes
closes à l'image de ce gérant de
discothèque située en bourgogne
v par ouvrir mon établissement ce
week-end c'est évidemment à contrecoeur
c'est un réel des champs mais on à
l'heure actuelle une conjoncture au
niveau 2 au niveau de ce qui nous est
imposée pour travailler qui ne qui me
laisse pas serein pour pour ce week end
heures ouverture donc donc non voilà sur
les 1600 discothèque que compte le pays
152 avait mis la clé sous la porte fin
mars plus de 200 se trouverait
actuellement en grande difficulté selon
les données du syndicat national des
discothèques
en dépit de leur autorisation de
réouverture les boîtes de nuit ne sont
toujours pas à la fête
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
un rush a gâché les médias américains
tom kerr carlson journée nice part de la
très conservatrice chaîne fox news est
que j'en ai fait là est née celle agence
nationale de sécurité d'avoir voulu
l'évincer de l'antenne et la faire
quelque chose guy qui revient sur le
devant de la scène le procès de 26
personnes accusées d'avoir participé à
l'assassinât du journaliste a repris
aujourd'hui à istanbul sont les accusés
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis que le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers étaient compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rexy le vrai
sujet c'est celui de faire dialoguer les
douaniers français les poignées
britannique est ce qui m'inquiète dans
le bric site c'est pas le break 6 et la
bureaucratie du proxy comment ça va se
passer par exemple pour l'éthique qui
arrive la côte d'azur verra peu ou pas
d'anglais je suspecte effectivement le
gouvernement britannique d'essayer de
convaincre les britanniques de rester en
grande bretagne pour faciliter la
relance de l'économie britannique par
rapport à la crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution
un supporter est d'une nécessité
technologique absolue les terres rares
sont au coeur des défis du 21e siècle
c'est un enjeu stratégique pour tous les
pays puisque leur accès est aujourd'hui
principalement chinois en l'état actuel
des capacités minières connu la part
chinoise et réserve mondiale est de
l'ordre de 37 % dans la cadre de la
guerre commerciale avec les états unis
la chine utilise sa position comme
levier de négociations mais il est clair
qu'avec les pénuries et les tensions que
nous allons connaître sur certaines
terreur il faut envisager d'autres
solutions
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous savez
pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vingt ans
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez aux etats
unis une affaire politico médiatique qui
suscite la polémique
un animateur de la chaîne fox news
affirme avoir été surveillé par la nfl
des accusations qui ont contraint agence
à réagir mais la polémique continue
d'enfler pour plus de précision on
retrouve tout de suite notre reporter
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
voir thomas alors tout d'abord qui est
ce fameux animateur que à qui on
reproche donc et que lui reproche-t-on
concrètement
bonsoir stéphanie alors tucker carlson
c'est l'animateur vedette de la chaîne
foxnews il est à l'antenne tous les
soirs à 20h pour une tranche qui réuni
en moyenne 3 millions de téléspectateurs
ce qu'ils ont fait l'émission la plus
regardée parmi toutes les chaînes
d'informations ici aux etats unis
tucker carlson c'est un peu le porte
voix des conservateurs il se montre très
critique contre les démocrates et donc
le 28 juin dernier il affirme à
l'antenne qu'un lanceur d'alert l'a
averti qu'il était surveillé par la
haine et c'est qu'ils chercheraient à
faire fuiter des informations sur
l'animateur sur toker carlson donc afin
de faire déprogrammer son émission cette
déclaration a provoqué une très vive
polémique avec d'abord d'un côté ceux
qui se sont offusqués de possibles
agissements la sorte de la part de la
nsa et puis de l'autre ceux qui n'ont
pas vraiment cru les affirmations de
tucker carlson affirmant qu'ils étaient
en train de mentir pour créer le buzz
mais la polémique a pris une telle
ampleur que finalement c'est la haine
essai qui a pris position uniquement ce
qui est très rare elle a publié un
communiqué sur son compte twitter pour
démentir formellement les accusations de
toker carlson écouter cette allégation
et foster carlson n'a jamais été une
cible de nos services il a aimé ça n'a
jamais eu pour projet d' essayer de
retirer son émission de l'antenne et
malgré ce démenti l'annoncé de nouvelles
révélations ont été faites
ces dernières heures thomas avec un
nouvel élément vladimir poutine
oui voilà de nouvelles informations qui
ont émergé ces dernières heures ici aux
etats unis
tucker karlsson a affirmé qu'il avait
été surveillé par cette agence de
renseignement parce qu'il prévoyait de
réaliser l'interview avec vladimir
poutine et que pour cela ils étaient en
lien avec des entremetteurs des
intermédiaires pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
caler justement cette interview avec le
président russe selon l'animateur de fox
news la nsf voulait justement mettre en
évidence des liens entre lui et ses
fameuses intermédiaire us pour le faire
passer pour quelqu'un de déloyale voire
un agent de l'étranger et le contenu des
emails de tucker carlson c'est encore
une fois lui qui l'affirment ce contenu
de ces mails auraient circulé auprès
d'un certain nombre de journalistes à
washington avec son nom donc ce n'était
pas des mails anonymes il ya des
informations qui ont également été
publiées sur le site
axios qui a demandé une nouvelle
réaction à la nsa avec ces nouvelles
informations la nsn n'a pas souhaité
réagir se contentant du communiqué
qu'elle avait déjà publié donc pour
démentir ces affirmations alors du côté
de tucker carlson on affirme qu'il y à
une instrumentalisation des services de
renseignements à des fins politiques
écoutez ce qu'il a déclaré c'était hier
soir ici aux etats-unis sur fox news
on ne peut pas avoir des services de
renseignements utilisés comme des
instruments de contrôle politique
les deux parties étaient d'accord là
dessus les démocrates étaient
particulièrement inflexibles là dessus
plus maintenant à prévoir une interview
avec le président russe vladimir poutine
ne pourrait pas justifier en soi d'être
surveillés par les services de
renseignement et surtout pas à ce que
son nom soit divulgué de la sorte il
faut rappeler aussi que la chaîne nbc
news a réalisé une interview avec
vladimir poutine s'était il ya moins
d'un mois en marge de sa rencontre avec
le président américain joe biden alors
pour tucker carson et les conservateurs
il faut rendre des comptes il demande
des comptes de la part des autorités
compétentes et surtout il estime qu'il
s'agit d'une nouvelle illustration d'une
possible instrumentalisation des
institutions à des fins politiques par
l'administration démocrate
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington est toujours aux etats-unis
une rencontre entre le vice ministre
saoudien de la défense et le secrétaire
d'état américain
une excellente réunion pour renforcer
les liens entre washington et ryad après
les mots du prince khalid bin salman et
anthony blinken
un entretien alors que les procès des
assassins de ammal cash audi reprend
aujourd'hui en turquie 26 personnes
soupçonnées d'avoir participé au meurtre
du journaliste saoudien dans le consulat
d'arabie saoudite d'istanbul en octobre
2018 problème le banc des accusés
restent vides
retour sur les faits avec maxime a bola
le 12 octobre 2018
jamal race audi seront au consulat
d'arabie saoudite à istanbul en turquie
pour deux simples démarches
administratives
du moins c'est ce qu'il croit
car le journaliste saoudien se retrouve
finalement piégé à l'intérieur de
l'édifice séquestré puis torturé il n'en
ressortira pas vivant
son corps est démembré et ses restes
n'ont jamais été retrouvés une affaire
qui éclabousse alors l'arabie saoudite
et notamment le prince héritier mohammed
bin salman soupçonné d'être le
commanditaire de son meurtre alors que
jamal race oggi un temps proche du
prince est devenu l'un de ses principaux
opposants
un temps très flou la sphère s'éclaircit
au fil des jours notamment sous la
pression de la turquie et des états unis
puisque le journaliste saoudien s'était
réfugié sur le sol américain et était
devenu chroniqueur pour le washington
post
ryad adoptent une stratégie défensive
non jamal race au guide n'a pas été
assassinés dans leur consulat mais le
pouvoir saoudien doit faire marche
arrière rapidement des enregistrements
audio et vidéo et dévoilerait bien le
meurtre du journaliste dans l'enceinte
du consulat saoudien la sphère
s'éclaircit mais le tableau se noircit
également on y apprend qu'il s'agit d'un
meurtre prémédité commis par une équipe
d'agents saoudien qui auraient été
envoyés par ryad
avec toujours comme principal
commanditaire suspects et mohamed ben
salman deux de ses proches seraient
impliqués dans la sphère son ancien chef
adjoint des services de
renseignements le général ahmed al asiri
et son ancien conseiller à la cour
royale
saud al qahtani céder aux responsables
saoudiens font partie des 26 accusés par
le tribunal d'istanbul pour le meurtre
de jamal race oggi mais ni lui ni les
autres prévenus ne seront présents au
tribunal
ryad ne voulant pas les livres et la
justice turque un procès complexe depuis
son ouverture il ya un an le 3 juillet
2020 de nouveaux éléments sont venus
agrémenter la polémique mondiale autour
de l'assassinât de jamal race oggi
dernier rebondissement en date le 26
février dernier un rapport a été rendu
public par la direction du renseignement
américain sous l'impulsion de joe biden
un rapport qui accuse mohamed ben salman
d'abord à prouvy l'assassinât de jamal
race oggi et pour en parler nous sommes
avec gérard haas pierre analyse
politique fondateur du site le mans
décrypter bonsoir gérard vespière merci
d'être avec nous un procès qui semble
donc doublement condamné à ne pas
aboutir puisque d'une part les accusés
sont absents info d'extradition et que
la turquie sont vouloir se réconcilier
avec ryad qu'elle peut être selon vous
dans ce contexte son issue on va écouter
je pense que la porte va doucement se
refermer parce que d'abord il ya aussi
eu un un procès en arabie saoudite même
n'est ce pas il ya eu 11 personnes sur
le banc des accusés cinq condamnations à
mort trois condamnations de prison et
trois acquittements dans voyez vous il
ya eu aussi ce volet de la faire donc je
crois que la turquie un besoin un de
ceux de renouer des contacts avec
l'arabie saoudite pour des questions
économiques et aussi ces questions
économiques sont destinés à améliorer à
l'image intérieure du président erdogan
car il est en difficulté sur le plan
économique et il a besoin effectivement
de retrouver des flux commerciaux avec
l'arabie saoudite
oui parce qu'il faut préciser que toutes
les exportations ont baissé
90% dans le pays et les dirigeants turcs
s'abstiennent du coup désormais
d'évoquer cet assassinat est pointé du
doigt publiquement le le trône saoudien
tout à fait vous avez cité ce chiffre
avant que je ne le fasse donc il y a un
besoin parce que l'économie turque est
en retournement après quinze années
glorieuses 2000 à 2015 maintenant il ya
eu six dia tôt cette année des
difficultés avec la situation du coc
vide
avec la sécheresse l'environnement est
tout à fait défavorables et récolte de
blé sont à 30% à la baisse cette année
en prévision donc voilà il y aura moins
de touristes à cause du coc vide
vraiment l'arabie saoudite a besoin
d'une aide extérieure pour que le
président r de gamme qui luttent contre
le temps car il ya des présidentielles
en turquie en juin 2023 donc c'est
bientôt très bientôt alors que en arabie
saoudite
eh bien on est dans le temps long le
prince est jonnie les héritiers s'il n'y
a pas de d'avatar il a quelques dizaines
d'années devant lui alors que le
président erdogan il ya quelques
dizaines de mois seulement alors à cet
assassinat qu'on sait particulièrement
brutale 1 prouve selon certains experts
l'excès de confiance de -25 man et
l'impunité que lui procure le
blanc-seing américain cette impunité est
ce qu'elle est toujours d'actualité avec
la mandature byden haut il n'y a pas
d'impunité je pense que on est là à la
limite ne sont pas des choses les
etats-unis ont ont laissé apparaître des
dossiers qui effectivement un implique
le nbs babel salamane lui même
habilement dit dès le départ
pratiquement à je suis responsable
ça veut dire je ne suis pas coupable
n'est ce pas on connaît la fameuse
formule en france responsable mais pas
coupable
donc il a sous son autorité des gens qui
auraient a effectivement lancé cette
opération
mais il faut savoir il faut savoir que
kashmiri était sur le point d'être nommé
un porte-parole international des frères
musulmans est donc là on est dans cette
bataille politique entre les familles
princières de l'arabie saoudite et de
tout le golfe et donc dé la stratégie
des frères musulmans d'un pouvoir civil
même avec une connotation bien sûr
fortement religieuse alors on sait
pourtant que rabaska chaude y étaient au
départ assez proche du pouvoir et
notamment du du prince héritier saoudien
quelles ont été les raisons de cette
dissidence
je pense qu'il a amené sa propre
évaluation de la situation et donc il a
il a souhaité s'éloigner du pouvoir
royal
le pouvoir royal l'a averti en disant
qu'il le prenait effectivement des
risques lui a proposé de revenir et de
continuer à travailler en arabie
saoudite
certainement avec des incentive que l'on
dit en mauvais français n'est ce pas des
incitations à à venir à nouveau ses
tables iran en arabie saoudite
il a refusé et donc effectivement la
situation est devenue un un peu hors de
contrôle mais se place politiquement
dans le conflit la tension entre les
frères musulmans et les pouvoirs donc
monarchique de l'arabie saoudite et du
golfe j'èspère ma dernière question
on a le sentiment d'une forme
d'indulgence en tout de même envers
l'arabie saoudite
imaginons que ça soit la russie avec
l'aval en avril a dit mirko team qui
serait responsable mais pas coupable
ça sent règlerait à coups de sanctions
oui c'est une bonne analyse mais vous
voyez vous quand il y à des
interventions d'état il y a des
ministres français qui se sont retrouvés
dans des étangs il y à des opposants
russes qui ont été aussi l'éliminer donc
voilà il y a les raisons d'état ils font
que quelquefois les choses ne vont pas
plus loin
très bien c'est clair merci gérard
vespière je rappelle que quand vous êtes
analyste géopolitique merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france une
première en nouvelle calédonie après
cinq mois de vacance du pouvoir
indépendantistes kanaks vient d'être élu
à la tête du gouvernement collégial
locale un signe politique fort à
quelques mois du dernier référendum
d'autodétermination de l'accord de
nouméa de 98 les détails en images avec
solène voilà ce 8 juillet 2021 louis
mapou devient le premier indépendantiste
président du gouvernement collégial de
la nouvelle calédonie depuis l'accord de
nouméa en 1998
ce fonctionnaire de 62 ans membre de
l'union nationale de l'indépendance est
engagé en politique parmi les
indépendantistes depuis ces trente ans
cette élection met fin à une crise
institutionnelle de plus de cinq mois
entre les partis indépendantistes lui
eni a fait lenka est élu c'est qu'ils se
disputaient la présidence le ministre d
outre-mer sébastien lecornu a adressé
ses félicitations à louis mas poux
l'invitant à une rencontre prochainement
à paris louis mapou veut donner la
priorité à deux dossiers
en premier lieu la réouverture des
frontières d'ici la fin de l'année
depuis mars 2020 la nouvelle calédonie a
fortement réduit ses liaisons aériennes
en raison de la crise sanitaire
le nouveau président du gouvernement
entend aussi mettre l'accent sur la
lutte contre les inégalités contre la
dérive d'une partie de la jeunesse kanak
et contre les violences faites aux
femmes
juste après son élection
louis mas poux a rendu hommage à la
cause indépendantiste et à une figure du
nationalisme kanak assassiné le 4 mai
1989 à ouvéa
nous arrivons au moment le plus
difficile de l'histoire de la nouvelle
calédonie de ces trente dernières années
c'est un honneur et un privilège on doit
porter un héritage qui est lourd celui
de notre figure de proue jean marie
tjibaou
cette élection intervient à quelques
mois seulement d'un moment clé de
l'histoire de la nouvelle calédonie le
troisième et dernier référendum sur
l'indépendance de l'archipel qui doit se
tenir le 12 décembre 2021
lors des deux premier référendum
organisé en novembre 2018 et en octobre
2020 le non à l'indépendance l'a emporté
avec respectivement 56,7 pour cent et
53,3 % des suffrages quel que soit le
résultat du prochain référendum
il sera suivi d'une période de
transition jusqu'à la tenue d'un
référendum de projets avant le 30 juin
2000 23 qui devra permettre
l'approbation de nouvelles institutions
on en parlait nous sommes avec un agent
en tenait photojournaliste pour le média
outre-mer 360° bonsoir jean
ato d'être avec nous alors tout d'abord
cours représente cette élection d'un
président kanak pour la nouvelle
calédonie c'est historique c'est vrai ce
qui n'était pas arrivé depuis l'accord
de nouméa et l'institution du
gouvernement collégial
en 1998 il ya déjà eu un un chef du
gouvernement calédonien face était le
conseil de gouvernement calédonien
c'était en
entre 1982 et 1984 et c'était justement
jean marie tjibaou qui a profité d'une
d'un désaccord entre les deux groupes
loyalistes pour accéder dans que alors à
l'époque c'était la vice-présidence du
conseil du gouvernement parce que le
président s'était le commissaire et
c'était surtout un rôle symbolique lui
était vraiment le chef de l'exécutif us
à l'époque on sait qu'il ya un grand
débat dans en nouvelle calédonie
évidemment sur cette question
d'indépendance comment cette élection
est perçu par la population
vous voulez parler du référendum
oui oui comment est-elle perçue par la
pop oublier oui alors c'est quelque
chose que que les calédoniens attend
depuis longtemps ils ont vécu dix ans
grandit certains ont grandi avec ça donc
ils savent ils connaissent tous les
connaissent tous les enjeux ils savent
ils savent exactement ce ce que ça
représente en tout cas pour coup leur
archipel est il n'y a qu'à voir les taux
de participation qui sont des taux de
participation qui frôle je crois qu'au
dernier au dernier référendum on a frôlé
les 90 % de taux de taux de
participation c'est dire l'importance
que représente cet enjeu électoral
qu'avant à ce que cette victoire est due
à la relative unification des forces
indépendantistes qui a été réalisé par
par l'onema pont
alors oui c'est vrai que l'accord entre
les deux les deux grands groupes
indépendantistes a mis du temps à
déboucher les grands groupes sont
indépendantiste en reste et compétents
dans cinq moins sûr sur leur sur leurs
positions qu'ils ont mis ils ont mis du
temps à lens avec eux louis mapou avait
une personnalité plus consensuel samuel
l'épée ou n'était pas forcément apprécié
par par l'ensemble des électorale
indépendantistes et et puis il ya eu il
est cet accord donc qui va déboucher sur
sur la présidence du congrès à la fin du
mois de juillet c'est c'est un partage
des pouvoirs entre les deux grands
groupes politiques abondante histoire
donc maintenant on va voir si on fasse
les non indépendantistes vont réussir à
apprendre le congrès et court-circuité
cet accord indépendantiste alors c'est
un signe positif tout de même assez fort
à quelques mois du référendum et
pourtant l'opinion reste majoritairement
contre l'indépendance qu'est-ce que ça
laisse présager selon vous alors je
honnêtement je ne saurais pas je saurais
pas dire enfin faire des prévisions sur
sur ce que ce que ça pourrait donner
dans tous les cas là les
indépendantistes y joue un il jouait un
défi majeur avant ce troisième
référendum c'est de prouver qu'il que
leur projet que que le projet
indépendantiste est un projet viable et
et qui peut et qui peut tout à fait est
que et que les calédoniens peuvent tout
à fait voter oui à l'indépendance sans
avoir de crainte donc il sent dans un
moment où ils vont relever un défi
prendre un risque surtout prendre un
risque parce que c'est aussi à risque de
perdre de perdre de l'électorat et
finalement de rater un peu l'exécutif la
lumière en tout cas nous sommes un point
évoqué après son émission luis attaque
ad
dossiers très importants comme la
réouverture inde et des frontières et
des crises et des finances publiques
dernière petite question quel est l'état
de l'archipel après plus d'un an de
crise sanitaire
alors je pense qu'il faut remonter un
peu plus loin pour connaître un peu
l'état de l'archipel à 2018 avec le
premier référendum d'autodétermination
je pense que s'il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes qui s'est installé depuis
depuis 2018 à certitude économies que
l'incertitude politique incertitudes
sociale et c'est vraiment ajouter à cela
l'épidémie enfin l'apprend d'amy c'est
moi un climat d'incertitude il ya eu le
dossier de lusine vallée qui a pu être
être au final il ya eu un accord là
dessus donc ça a pu être réglée il est
ensuite il ya eu ce ce gouvernement qui
n'est pas encore jusqu'ici entrée en
exercice et qui est revenu encore ajouté
de l'incertitude on s'est vraiment un
climat je pense d'incertitude sur place
merci beaucoup photo je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste un puro les médias
outre-mer 360 degrés merci à vous
et dans la zone l'actualité en afrique
du sud jacob zuma 79 ans l'ex président
est condamné à un an et trois mois de
réclusion pour outrage une première qui
a valeur de test à pretoria retour sur
ce feuilleton judiciaire rocambolesque
avec grégoire douce et il s'agit d'une
première pour un président de l'époque
post-apartheid en afrique du sud après
avoir joué au chat et à la souris avec
la justice
jacob zuma au pouvoir entre 2009 et 2010
8 a été incarcéré durant la nuit dans
une prison de l'est du pays
il est arrivé juste après une heure du
matin
vous savez qu'en tant qu'ancien
président il a une unité de protection
présidentielle
ils nous l'ont amené mais maintenant
nous devons prendre le relais et je dois
m'assurer qu'il est incarcéré en toute
sécurité et nous devons également
répondre à ces besoins spéciaux s'ils
ont été identifiés a mis en cause dans
une quarantaine de témoignages est
condamné à quinze mois de réclusion pour
outrage après avoir refusé de témoigner
devant une commission anti corruption et
jacob zuma a multiplié les recours en
justice pour éviter de passer par la
case prison et malgré une première nuit
en cellule il porte encore l'espoir
d'une révision de sa sentence
une nouvelle audience aura lieu en ce
sens le 12 juillet alors qu'il a déjà
passé une décennie derrière les barreaux
aux côtés de nelson mandela
l'homme âgé de 79 ans est dépeint comme
étant capable du meilleur comme du pire
elle déclarait il ya quelques jours ne
pas être effrayé à l'idée de retourner
en prison
à nantes ed je n'ai pas peur d'aller en
prison pour mes convictions for my billy
je le demande pas la sympathie on met la
joie this mon âge mon état de santé ndn
et ada et toute autre circonstance
atténuante n'ont pas été prises en
compte
well note coincé dadou
figure de la lutte anti-apartheid ce
combattant pour la liberté conserve une
cote de popularité non négligeable dans
son pays
mais ces neuf années au pouvoir marqués
par une succession de scandales se sont
terminées par une démission devenue
inévitable dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la flambée d'épidémie dans
certains territoires d'outre-mer à la
réunion et en martinique le taux
d'incidence explose
et puis nous évoquerons les géo tokyo la
ministre japonaise des jeux olympiques
annoncé que la compétition se tiendrait
sans public
[Musique]
merci on a identifié un peu plus de 500
depuis un an et demi les alertes
concernant les menaces de prédation sur
des entreprises françaises se
multiplient en vous avez un pays qui est
affaibli par une crise économique
majeure
ça intéresse les prédateurs parce qu'ils
savent que vous ne pourrez pas vous
défendre
ça peut le chacun pour soi dieu pour
tous actuellement dans cette guerre
économique et le darwinisme classique et
économiques et les gros mangent les
petits mais là on se trouve devant un
nouveau type de risque le droit est
maintenant utilisée par les états pour
aider leurs entreprises notamment à
affaiblir d'autres entreprises
étrangères
tous les gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
ministère de l'économie ne savent pas ce
que c'est qu'une entreprise s'ils ont
jamais mis les pieds
donc ne leur demandez pas à défendre
quelque chose qu'ils ne connaissent pas
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame 50 négociations
politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 est à autre c'est juste
quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre 20 perd gros là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement à des dissidents
par votre mouvement c'est des
accusations politiques qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les allégations portées devant
la justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé ni les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui sont fermés est-ce
que désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi quand la guerre a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum interne à
sion vous laissez les sahraouis le choix
de choisir le futur de choisir entre
l'indépendance et l'intégration maroc à
savoir que ce n'est pas une partie du
territoire marocain
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise ces firmes
mais comment peuvent-ils mentir comme
des arracheurs de dents à ce point
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 8 juillet même
sans variant delta l'épidémie flanc dans
les territoires français d'outre-mer en
guyane où le taux de contamination reste
au dessus du seuil d alerte les couvre
feu donc on me fait toujours en vigueur
c'est ton martinique que la situation se
détériore le plus les condamne une
contamination se sont multipliées par
quatre en une semaine et le port du
masque est à nouveau obligatoire sur la
voie publique depuis ce jeudi alors que
le variant delta plus continue sa
progression 60000 spectateurs sont
attendus pour la finale de l'euro qui se
déroulera ce dimanche à londres
des spectateurs aux jo de tokyo en
revanche il n'y en aura pas déclaration
tout à l'heure de la ministre japonaise
des jeux olympiques du report au huis
clos le comité a failli fini par
trancher
[Musique]
l'inflation galope non seulement aux
états unis mais aussi chez nous en
europe pour la france l'insee l'estimé à
5% sur un an en juin
plus que le mois précédent à l'heure où
la forte reprise post pandémie créer des
pénuries sur certaines matières
premières allons nous connaître une
hausse généralisée des prix et si oui
pour combien de temps autant de
questions auxquelles l'économiste
jacques sapir tentera de répondre
[Musique]
suite des consultations avant un énième
conseil de défense sanitaire de lundi
prochain à l'elysée l'exécutif prend
cette fois le plus des élus locaux au
sujet de la vaccination obligatoire pour
le corps médical leit motiv du
gouvernement vacciner à tout prix pour
éviter une quatrième vague ont fait le
point avec mona amont dès lors depuis
matignon
c'est au tour de jean castex de
recueillir l'avis des associations
d'élus lors d'une grande consultation et
concernant la vaccination obligatoire à
des soignants et l'extension du pass
sanitaire avec en ligne de mire un
projet de loi à ce sujet pour le moment
dans les ehpad les soignants sont
vaccinés à 57 % et 64 % dans les
hôpitaux mais ce n'est pas assez
selon olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé depuis plusieurs jours le
gouvernement se prépare doucement face à
la montée des cas puisque le variant
delta gagne du terrain c'est une réalité
selon santé publique ils représentent
43,5 pour cent des cas de contamination
en france et 55 % en ile-de-france de
son côté le gouvernement continue à
réfléchir à des mécanismes d'incitation
à la vaccination
mais l'exécutif le sait il marche sur
les oeufs et il ne veut pas brusquer les
aides soignants et qui ont durement
travaillé et qui ont été éprouvés
pendant la crise sanitaire mais il veut
être en même temps ferme lundi 12
juillet se tiendra un conseil sanitaire
de dépenses et toutes ces questions
seront abordées telles épidémies flanc
dans plusieurs territoires français
d'outre-mer + 12 % de cas la réunion en
une semaine
en guyane le couvre feu est toujours en
vigueur le taux de contamination reste
au dessus du seuil d alerte et c'est en
martinique la situation se détériore le
plus les contaminations se sont
multipliées par quatre en une semaine
le port du masque est à nouveau
obligatoire sur la voie publique depuis
ce jeudi l'inquiétude monte dans ces
régions pourtant épargné par le mariant
delta mais où le taux de vaccination est
inférieure à la moyenne nationale
et pour en parler nous sommes avec anne
criquets au médecin généraliste
président de l'union régionale
des médecins libéraux de martinique
bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous on
vient de dire certains territoires
d'outre-mer qui connaissent à nouveau
pic épidémique qui n'est pas du
curieusement variant delta mais à la
souche originel ou britanniques au sud
africaine comment expliquer cette
particularité et la pénétration
quasi-nul du delta la particularité il
s'explique par le taux faible de
vaccination malheureusement de la
population martiniquaise la
contamination actuellement est une
contamination autochtones donc ça veut
dire que les gens n'étant pas vacillé ce
qu'on t'a mis d'eux mêmes et avec une
contamination par des jeunes individus
et les jeunes individus ne sont pas
vaccinés on a eu un taux de pénétration
de la vaccination plus important chez
des personnes plus âgées est
actuellement toutes les mesures sont
essayés pour augmenter cette vaccination
qui sera le seul moyen de lutter contre
la propagation avec même l'autorisation
donc en ville dans les cabinets de
pouvoir utiliser du kaiser aussi bien
chez les médecins que les pharmaciens
que les infirmiers pour la politique de
la les verts qui est déployée par la
grèce et par la préfecture mais
actuellement bas les jeunes ont un
sentiment de liberté ont envie de
liberté et la contamination de petits
groupes qui avait supprimé les mesures
barrières qui ne sont pas vaccinés qui
ont envie de se retrouver dans la plage
d'aller dans un système plus festif et
va malheureusement se contaminent
contaminent les autres et avec un risque
de tension qui est déjà signalé à
l'hôpital avec une mise en alerte étant
donné que nous sommes sur une île que de
deux possibilités d'évacuation donc nous
faisons très attention pour essayer de
circonscrire au maximum d'où les
nouvelles mesures annoncées par monsieur
le préfet de renforcement avec le port
du masque avec les mesures de
restriction dans les lieux publics
inscrits sont annoncés comment expliquez
vous ces chiffres aussi faible de la
vaccination en outre-mer
je pense que premièrement comme on était
très peu impactée par l'aco vide
donc tant mieux pour nous mais la
population n'a pas pris forcément
conscience de la gravité de la crau vide
et de cette nécessité de se faire
vacciner donc on a eu un impact très
modéré donc le vaccin oui oui je vais
penser j'attends avoir un peu plus de
recul
les patients sont assez réticents alors
vous avez de population et les gens qui
ont voulu ce pacte il est très vite
qu'ils sont venus en premier et puis
d'autres qui se dit bon on va voir on
est loin on était assez préservé on y
arrive parce que des mesures de
protection qui avaient été mis aussi
bien par les bateaux de croisière que
les mesures sanitaires aux frontières
l'avantagé c'est qu'on arrive quand même
à protéger aussi bien par bateau que par
avion ont permis de préserver la
martinique et avec des mesures
d'isolement où la population avait bien
joué le jeu avec des mesures de port de
masques et qui étaient respectés
actuellement la population plus jeune et
c'est elle qui est infecté on le voit
très nettement de relais dans les
statistiques nous sont remontés donne
justement cette fragilité au avec ce
sentiment de liberté comme l'expliqué
précédemment bah non plus on vit
longtemps vie ne se sont pas très active
et donc bien sûr ce conte annie et vous
avez les étudiants qui vont rentrer qui
rentrent dans leur famille et ainsi de
suite avec un avec toutes ces
problématiques
alors justement la période estivale
c'est aussi le moment du retour dans
leur région d'origine pour de nombreux
ultra marins notamment les étudiants
vous venez de société comment la
population à prendre cet été
sous cloche puisqu'il ya encore des
restrictions en outre-mer mais pour le
moment aux restrictions sous cloche
puisque le là on n'a pas de mesures
qualité exceptionnelle comme vous prenez
l'avion pour venir au mans martinique
actuellement vous devez présenter un
test pcr il voulait pas activé vous
devez avoir une période d'isolement de
sept jours
mais si les voyages avec les mesures
d'exception sont remis un sont remis en
vigueur on va totalement changer la
donne donc actuellement les patients les
pas des passions et la déformation
professionnelle les les voyageurs quand
ils arrivent ils doivent avoir une
semaine d'isolement filles sont pas
vaccinés qui n'est pas forcément
toujours très respecté mais actuellement
la problématique de la flambée aux
marques et qu'elle n'est pas dû aux
voyageurs on a seulement 1% de
contamination qui viennent d d'autre
part qui viennent des voyageurs la
contamination pour 99% et autochtones
cela veut dire que le virus circule en
martinique et que les gens ont levé les
mesures barrières on ne prennent plus
des précautions nécessaires
non effectivement vous l'aviez dit en ce
début d'interview mais enfin c'est sûr
qu'avec cette entre guillemets
transhumances estivales
il ya ce risque désormais aussi de
contamination aux variants delta très
contagieux mais bien sûr bien sûr avec
toute la fragilité imposée par le
système sanitaire qui est déjà en
fragilité aux entier puisque nous avons
un hôpital sous tension avec beaucoup de
deux soignants un petit peu en burn out
avec beaucoup mais aussi d'arrêt maladie
avec un personnel soignant souffrance
avec des soignants libéraux qui ont été
sur le front dès la première heure
donc ce sont aussi fatigués qu'ils ont
besoin de vacances est un chant qu'on ne
pouvait pas voyager comme ça qu'il y
avait les mesures de sa mêlée on ne
pouvait pas prendre l'avion si on
n'avait pas un motif impérieux de
voyager donc avec cette levée des motifs
impérieux il ya eu un vent de liberté
qui a permis aussi de souffler mais
actuellement bas tout le monde se pose
la question qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire donc notre
rôle mois
donc notre rôle au nom de l'union
régionale des médecins libéraux de
martinique et d'inviter la population
martiniquaise à se faire vacciner
beaucoup plus amplement et je veux dire
toutes les mesures sont en place ou un
absolument pas de pénurie avec une
possibilité de se faire vacciner en
ville aussi bien par l'infirmier que par
le médecin que par le pharmacien
justement pour faciliter cette proximité
donc il faut avoir recours à la à la
vaccination pour avoir une unité
collective pour arriver à freiner cette
diffusion à l'inter en intra martinique
merci beaucoup à nos geeks et ayo
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france pour nous exposer cette situation
en outre-mer et notamment et
particulièrement en martinique est
toujours en france les établissements de
nuit rouge
quant à eux demain après 16 mois de
fermeture une réouverture son conditions
strictes plus d'explications avec
estelle farges depuis le quartier de
pigalle à paris où de nombreuses
discothèques sont concentrés rendez vous
sur la piste de danse c'est avec ces
mots que le ministre délégué chargé des
pme a annoncé sur twitter le 21 juin
dernier la réouverture des boîtes de
nuit un rendez vous que certains
établissements n'ont pas envie d'honorer
selon le syndicat national des
discothèques et lieux de loisirs et
cette boîte de nuit sur 10 devraient
rester fermés ce 9 juillet conséquence
du très contraignant protocole sanitaire
demandé aux établissements
il y a tout d'abord les jauges de
remplissage les boîtes de nuit ne
pourront pas dépasser 75 % de leur
capacité d'accueil habituelle
et puis le pass sanitaires pour pouvoir
accéder à la piste de danse il faudrait
être en possession d'un test pcr datant
de moins de 48 heures ou d'un test
antigénique prouvant l'absence de
contamination ou alors d'une preuve de
vaccination complète ou encore d'un
certificat de rétablissement datant de
plus de 15 jours mais de moins de six
mois sur la question du passé ni terre
le syndicat national des discothèques
pointe des incohérences au sein d'un
même type de métier aujourd'hui le pass
sanitaire est obligatoire dans les
établissements pouvant accueillir plus
de 1000 personnes en france seuls 40
boîtes de nuit ont cette capacité
d'accueil il dénonce aussi des
inégalités avec notamment les bars dans
sans nom
soumis à ce protocole sanitaire pour le
snd ll il s'agit tout simplement de
concurrence déloyale
certains préfèrent donc rester portes
closes à l'image de ce gérant de
discothèque située en bourgogne vais pas
rouvrir un établissement
ce week-end c'est évidemment à
contrecoeur
c'est un réel des champs mais on a à
l'heure actuelle une une conjoncture en
niveau 2 au niveau de ce qui nous est
imposée pour retravailler qui ne me
laisse pas serein pour pour ce week end
à ouverture donc donc non voilà sur les
1600 discothèque que compte le pays 152
avait mis la clé sous la porte fin mars
plus de 200 se trouverait actuellement
en grande difficulté selon les données
du syndicat national des discothèques
en dépit de leur autorisation de
réouverture les boîtes de nuit ne sont
toujours pas à la fête
en espagne les chiffres du commis 19
monte en flèche à tel point que la
france déconseillent de se rendre dans
certaines régions cet été comme en
catalogne
c'est un coup dur on le tourisme tout
début de la saison estivale les
précisions de clémentine laurent notre
correspondante à barcelone éviter de se
rendre en espagne et surtout en
catalogne c'est en tout cas ce que qu'on
saigne clément bonne le secrétaire
d'état français chargé des relations
avec l'europe en cause les
contaminations qui remonte en flèche en
espagne en effet le pays comptabilise
environ 40% des contaminations en europe
c'est un chiffre très alarmant et
surtout si l'on prend en compte la
propagation du variante delta seulement
ici à barcelone
ils représentent 40% des contaminations
et ce chiffre pourrait bien grimper à 60
% ces prochains jours selon les experts
alors même si l'ambassadeur espagnol en
france considèrent que les touristes
n'ont rien à craindre et 6 en espagne la
france mais aussi la belgique et
l'allemagne conseillent à leurs
ressortissants de ne pas se rendre dans
plusieurs régions espagnoles et
notamment la catalogne
c'est donc un coup dur pour le secteur
touristique ici notamment en économie de
barcelone qui a du mal à se remettre des
précédentes vagues de covin 19 qui ont
notamment limité le tourisme je vous
propose d'écouter à retour au solaire là
le directeur d'un hôtel à barcelone
biden approbation ces dernières semaines
il ya une progression claire des
réservations depuis que l'été a commencé
et qu'il fait plus chaud et l'évolution
était très positive au dessus des
chiffres de l'année dernière et des
derniers mois le changement s'est
produit il ya à peine 48 heures tout
s'est arrêté d'un coup les ventes sont
totalement figée c'est donc un véritable
coup de massue pour le secteur
touristique à barcelone donc mais il
faut rappeler que c'est aussi la flume
de touristes qui fait circuler le virus
c'est un peu le serpent qui se mord la
queue
et ici à barcelone il ya énormément de
touristes notamment de français qui
viennent faire la fête et qui se
regroupent dans les rues sur les plages
et dans les bars sans forcément de
distanciation social ni de masques alors
face à cette situation plutôt
préoccupante
le gouvernement catalan a pris des
mesures
dernière c'est de refermer les
discothèques seulement deux semaines
après leur réouverture alors cette
mesure est-elle suffisant pour freiner
la propagation du côté de 19
la réponse est non selon les médecins il
estime qu'il faudrait plutôt limité les
horaires d'ouverture et l'affluence des
bars et des restaurants
c'est en tout cas ce vers quoi on se
dirige pour ces prochains jours
ici en catalogne si la situation
sanitaire ne s'améliore pas très les
spectateurs aux jo de tokyo en revanche
il n'y en aura pas déclaration tout à
l'heure de la ministre japonaise des
jeux olympiques alors que le président
du cio thomas bach et on japon être
quentin mauclair des tribunes vides et
qui le resteront pour la première fois
de l'histoire des jeux olympiques se
dérouleront à huis clos décision du
gouvernement japonais ce jeudi en raison
d'un nouveau regain épidémique dans la
capitale un choix qui s'ajoute à la mise
en place d'un nouvel état d'urgence dans
l'agglomération de tokyo
les jeux de tokyo devait être une
occasion rare de ressentir la puissance
du sport à travers des stades pleins et
des communautés
cependant c'est avec regret qu'ils
doivent maintenant être organisée de
manière très limitée en raison de la
propagation du nouveau virus
je suis vraiment désolé pour les fans
qui ont acheté les billets et attendait
les jeux avec impatience à ce que pour
la population locale qui nomine à saint
magne à lima la capitale nippone en état
d'urgence jusqu'au 22 août prochain
outre tokyo
les compétitions se déroulant dans les
autres départements du pays
seront également interdites au public le
premier ministre japonais gardent espoir
d'assouplir les restrictions si la
situation s'améliore aussi nous
constatons une diminution du nombre de
l'ijba libé par les patients atteints du
coronavirus jeu pourrait raccourcir la
période de l'état d'urgence la tendance
ne va pour autant pas dans ce sens la
vaccination peine à trouver son rythme
seulement 15% des japonais sont
entièrement vacciner
concernant le nombre moyen de nouveaux
cas quotidiens il atteint les 1500
contre à peine 1000 sur la même période
l'an passé
la propagation du variante elle t'a fait
également craindre l'apparition d'une
nouvelle vague dans le pays
le nombre de nouveaux cas continuent
d'augmenter à tokyo avec l'augmentation
des déplacements de personnes le variant
delta plus infectieux représente
désormais environ 30 % des cas
ce chiffre devrait encore augmenter la
réinstauration de l'état d'urgence aura
des conséquences directes sur l'économie
au sein de l'agglomération
la vente d'alcool sera limité les bars
et restaurants fermeront plus tôt les
jeux olympiques débuteront donc le 23
juillet dans un contexte tendu puisque
la tenue de l'événement est de plus en
plus mal perçue par une partie de la
population tokyoïte desio d'ores et déjà
surnommé les jeux de la pandémie très a
contrario la polémique enfle
outre-manche sur le nombre de
spectateurs présents dans le stade pour
la demi-finale de l'euro alors que le
variant delta plus continue sa
progression en europe 70 spectateurs
étaient présents pour la demi finale
entre l'angleterre et le danemark dans
le stade de wembley pour la finale qui
se déroulera ce dimanche à londres
le même et la même maintenant de
téléspectateurs est attendue de
spectateurs surtout dans le stade en
visite dans le pays vendredi dernier la
chancelière angela merkel avait jugé ces
autorisations inquiétante et pour en
parler nous sommes avec roanne rosé
dorado journalistes espagnols
spécialistes sport bonsoir rendre aux
aidants ados merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france 60000 spectateurs
à wembley pour la demi finale on a vu
ses spectateurs entassés dans le stade
dans sa tranchée avec cette ambiance de
crise sanitaire qui perdure depuis plus
d'un an
c'est peut-être bien pour le sport mais
est-ce que ça n'a pas un côté un petit
peu insensé et déraisonnable
forcément que ça a un côté a un côté
insensé puisqu'on sait que du côté des
loups gris où effectivement il n'y avait
pas déjà eu des cas de contamination par
rapport aux supporters qui se sont
déplacés suivre les différents matchs
qui se sont déroulés en hongrie
notamment ceux de l'équipe de l'équipe
de france c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a
la sensation depuis 48 heures que la
pandémie prendre la vitesse que le virus
circule de plus en plus vite et dans
plus en plus grand nombre de pays etc l
uefa en fait n'est pas au courant dés ce
qui se passe parce qu'effectivement
maintenir 70 personnes dans la situation
actuelle dans un pays de toutes façons
en angleterre qui est fortement touchée
cc c'est dangereux pour les semaines
pour le semaines à venir juste te
rappeler est par exemple et qui a deux
villes qui aurait dû accueillir des
matches des 17 euros 2020 et qui ne
l'ont pas fait parce qu'elles n'ont pas
voulu suivre l'uefa en ce qui concerne
les jeux ce qui avait été établi
c'est le cadre des bilbao qui a renoncé
à recevoir des matches de la sélection
espagnole où c'est encore le cas des
dublin qui a aussi renoncé
donc on voit que depuis plusieurs
semaines il ya des pays il ya des villes
il ya des responsables politiques qui
disent attention
peut-être qu'on est en train de
commettre une erreur et on voit
aujourd'hui effectivement quelle à
l'uefa regarde pour l'instant à ailleurs
et pas dans la bonne direction
clairement
part de responsabilité conjointe de la
part de l'uefa qui a quand même mis la
pression sur les villes hôtes un pour
accueillir un maximum de supporters mais
aussi de la part des autorités
britanniques qui devront donc accepter
largement de ne jouer jour on l'a vu sur
les images hier
effectivement les les autorités
britanniques qui jouent le jeu entre
guillemets qui permettait 60000
personnes parce que ça les intéresse et
qu'économiquement parlons est sale et
s'intéresse et sportivement parlant
rappelant que les supporters étrangers
et sont ceux mis en quarantaine et donc
pour la plupart vont pouvoir pas y aller
voir les matchs du côté de l'angleterre
7 cette fameuse finale c'est vrai et que
l'uefa a fait pression sur différentes
villes encore cet exemple de bilbao qui
n'a pas voulu qu'il n'a pas voulu
accueillir donc des spectateurs dans son
stade et donc elle n'a pas eu des matchs
des del oro mais par contre dans le même
pays
séville a bien voulu accueillir des
spectateurs est donc ramené à ramener du
monde sur sur les stades
pourquoi parce que derrière ça nous
n'oublions pas on a passé des moments
très difficiles
et puis ça derrière l'aspect sportif il
ya un aspect financier est qui et qui
est évident il ya un aspect aussi
politique beaucoup des gouvernements
doivent quand même se rattraper par des
mauvaises politiques ou de la mauvaise
communication
tout au long de la dernière année suite
à la pandémie et donc le fait de ramener
l'euro chez eux et d'avoir du monde dont
dans les stades ça ça leur permet en
quelque sorte de se justifier auprès des
leurs populations donc la responsabilité
et le n'est pas uniquement et vous avez
tout à fait raison à l'uefa elle est
aussi aux autorités des différents pays
qui ont décidé d'accueillir du monde
mais elle est aussi donc bien évident
bien évidemment aux eaux au club qui ont
essayé effectivement de faire en sorte
que des milliers d des spectacles des
fans puisse suivre et leur leur équipe
même si c'était compliqué ça doit j'ai
complètement zappé pardonnez moi ça
paraît incroyable et effectivement quand
on voit ce stade rempli d'anglais les
pauvres d'ailleurs danois
on en fait les frais c'est pas vraiment
l'esprit sportif afin de permettre
uniquement aux supporters britanniques
d'être dans les stades et les autres et
bien tant pis à ses yeux puisque ils
n'ont pas la chance d'habiter au royaume
uni c'est ça sent le même choquant et
très discriminant vu de l'extérieur
c'est choquant c'est discriminant on
comprend pas effectivement les autorités
anglaises utilisé il ya il ya un côté
chauviniste chez les anglais
effectivement kiki qui interdisent la
c'est donc au stade aux supporters
bénodet de l'étranger ce qui est dommage
aussi c'est que les différents pays que
ce soit les danois les italiens les
espagnols etc
les gouvernements de ces pays n'est pas
fait pression eux à son tour sur sur le
gouvernement britannique qu'aux l'uefa
pour qu'il puisse y avoir d'autres
d'autres supporters mais là on a
vraiment de problème est qu'ils se
rejoignent mais qui sont complètement
différents d'un côté c'est la première
question que vous avez posé vous aviez
raison c est ce qu il est logique
d'avoir 60 mille personnes dans un stade
aujourd'hui quand on voit la circulation
du virus delta notamment et des ravages
qu'il peut faire est-ce que d'un autre
côté effectivement c est sportivement
parlant
normal que les supporteurs ne puisse pas
supporter leur équipe nationale parce
que il ya eu des décisions aux
politiques bas il faut juste se rappeler
et que les anglais n'ont pas gagné un
titre international depuis plus dix
cinquantaine d'années peut-être qu'avec
l'aide de l'uefa des arbitres et du
public anglais qui sera le solde de ce
talent ils vont réussir cette fois ci
merci en tout cas rendre aux et dorado
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france ce soir
et dans quelques instants rester avec
nous l'inflation guette aux états unis
mais aussi en france une festive
à 1 5% sur un an longue connaître une
hausse généralisée des prix
d'économistes jacques sapir tentera d'y
répondre enfin focus sur la
participation d' emmanuel macron au
sommet g5 celle ce sera vendredi où il
sera question du départ de la force de
barkan
[Musique]
oui
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une des plus importantes
compagnies de taxis en france l'activité
a repris sdap elmander paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
garé ya qu un 5/6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivé là
concurrents mais vtc gros gros choc
d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé les 20000 à
45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry allons
faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernière poche là ont profité en 2011 le
monde manque pas un petit peu non ah oui
c'est tous les fromages tous les soucis
sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les jantes
les gens très stylée les français ne le
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge et autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous savez
pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï tg les gens qui s'étaient des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose alors jean
francky
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
et
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
arte france si vous nous rejoignez
l'inflation galopante
non seulement aux états unis mais aussi
chez nous en europe
pour la france l'insee l'estimé à 5% sur
un an un peu plus que le mois précédent
à l'heure où la forte reprise post
pandémie créer des pénuries sur
certaines matières premières allons nous
connaître une hausse généralisée des
prix le phénomène est-il passagers ou
peut-il s'inscrire dans la durée on voit
ça tout de suite avec elle économise
jacques sapir c'est notre rubrique n'est
ni taux n'est pas en un an au mois de
juin jacques évidemment alors jacquin
quand on parle évidemment de l'inflation
c'est-à-dire de au sein des prix de quoi
parle-t-on exactement
oui bonjour stéphanie alors oui
effectivement on est aujourd'hui
confronté à une hausse des prix qui est
de l'ordre de 1,4 1,5 pour cent en tant
que tel ce n'est pas énorme mais ça
reste néanmoins significatifs et alors
surtout le problème que l'on se pose
c'est de savoir est ce que cette hausse
des prix qui semble lier effectivement à
des déséquilibres entre l'offre et la
demande
au fait que la demande est redémarré
plus vite que l'offre notamment et bien
est ce que ces déséquilibres vont être
passager auquel cas n'y a pas de raison
de s'inquiéter
ou bien vont-ils devenir plus
structurelle et là effectivement cela
demanderait un ajustement de la
politique économique
injac pour commencer cody lindsay sur
l'évolution de l'inflation
alors c'est un peu intéressants l'insee
indique que l'inflation qui avait
tendance à baisser et qui avait baissé
d'ailleurs assez fortement depuis le
début de 2010 9 jusqu'à atteindre un
point relativement bas en 2020 et bien
cette inflation a recommencé à augmenter
à la fin de 2020 et elle augmente
extrêmement vite
au point que aujourd'hui en juin elle a
atteint son nid
vous deux 2019 et l'on peut craindre
effectivement que cette inflation
continue d'augmenter et puissent
atteindre les 2% pourquoi pas les deux
et demi pourcent fin 2020 ou en 2021
donc ça c'est une dimension du problème
mais alors quelles sont les raisons
jacques de cette hausse alors une des
premières raisons c'est l'envolée des
prix des matières premières il faut
savoir que l'ensemble des matières
premières aujourd'hui par à la hausse
alors que ce soit l'énergie
on voit bien le prix du pétrole a
nettement augmenté aujourd'hui le
pétrole se négocie autour de 74 75
dollars le baril mais il ya aussi les
produits alimentaires à ce qu'on appelle
les matières premières agricoles
et là c'est plus qu'une eau est pris il
ya des phénomènes de pénurie qui
existent et qui pose aujourd'hui des des
vrais problèmes pour l'approvisionnement
dans toute une série de pays ça risque
d'ailleurs de provoquer des émeutes de
la faim
et puis il ya les métaux industriels
tous ses produits en fait sont inclus
dans les produits manufacturés que nous
consommons évidemment les matières
premières agricoles servent à faire nos
animaux et puis les métaux sont dans les
produits manufacturés comme les
automobiles les les caisses
d'électroménager quant à l'énergie bien
voilà tout le monde quand il passe à la
honte dans la semaine peut vérifier que
le prix de l'essence a nettement
augmenté depuis ces dernières semaines
et il a question évidemment concédons
vient cette hausse des matières
premières
quand il ya trois raisons
fondamentalement il ya trois raisons la
première raison c'est que la demande a
augmenté beaucoup plus vite que l'offre
1 a pu repartir alors la demande elle a
augmenté évidemment en chine mais aussi
aux états unis donc ça c'est un premier
problème la deux le deuxième problème
c'est la hausse des prix du commerce
maritime
ce qu'on appelle par exemple l' indice
baltic dry qui mesurent la tension si
vous voulez sur le commerce maritime et
bien cet indice baltic dry il
reparti à la hausse depuis grosso modo
juin 2020 et aujourd'hui il est à son
niveau le plus haut depuis 2014
donc ça c'est un poids qui va évidemment
dans le sens d'un accroissement du prix
de toutes les matières premières qu'il
faut bien transporter la troisième
raison est bien c'est la désorganisation
des chaînes logistiques qui n'ont pas
encore récupéré de la crise de l'aco
vide etc désorganisation que l'on avait
pensé d'abord être de très courte durée
mais on voit qu'elle va durer au moins
jusque fin 2020 voix 2021 est-ce qu'on
n'assiste pas aussi à une hausse des
produits manufacturés et jacques oui
tout à fait et pour les mêmes raisons en
réalité sur les produits manufacturés
on voit que là aussi la hausse de la
demande elle est plus rapide que le
redémarrage de l'offre bien sûr l'offre
va finir par redémarrer un mais pour
l'instant il ya un déséquilibre offre
demande qui est évident il y à aussi
justement ce problème du transport
cette hausse des coûts de transport et
puis il ya évidemment cette
désorganisation des chaînes logistiques
donc tout cela fait qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des tendances haussières à
la fois sur les matières premières et
sur les produits manufacturés
on peut penser et je crois que c'est
assez raisonnable de le penser que en
cela va se terminer que vers la fin 2022
les choses vont revenir à la normale
néanmoins ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
pic d'inflation il y aura un coût
d'inflation de la fin de 2020
au début disons à la fin du premier
semestre 2009 t1 jacques pour l'instant
vous n'avez pas évoquer des faits que
vous n'avez évoqué que des phénomènes de
l'économie réelle
est ce à dire que les injections monnaie
non pas stimuler l'inflation vous avez
tout à fait raison de poser cette
question
stéphanie parce que oui c'est un vrai
problème alors on le sait les banques
centrales ont injecté beaucoup d'argent
dans les économies alors que ce soit aux
états unis la réserve fédérale que ce
soit en europe la banque centrale
européenne pour justement soutenir
l'activité
au moment de la crise de la copie dos au
moment de la période et confinement le
problème c'est qu'une partie de cet
argent n'a pas été bien distribués si
vous voulez il ya des catégories
sociales de la population qui n'ont pas
du tout vu je dirais la couleur de cet
argent d'autres qui ont d'une certaine
manière vu la majorité de cet argent
arriver sur leur compte et concrètement
ça se traduit par deux phénomènes
le premier phénomène c'est la hausse des
cours boursiers si vous voulez c'est cet
argent va s'investir sur les marchés
financiers évidemment on sait bien que
c'est pas l'ensemble de la population
qui joue sur les marchés financiers
c'est une très petite couche qui joue
sur les marchés financiers donc ça c'est
déjà un premier effet de l'injection
d'eau d epuis le deuxième effet et
quitte extrêmement important c'est la
hausse des prix de l'immobilier est ce
que l'on constate c'est que cette hausse
des prix de l'immobilier
elle est aujourd'hui général dans
l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
vous savez y est des pays où cette
hausse elle a atteint 18% sur un an
bon la france est plutôt en retard de ce
côté là mais avec 9 % quand même
donc ça veut dire que ce que l'on
appelle les actifs patrimoniaux au
sommet dos les actions les obligations
mais surtout les actions et les biens
immobiliers sont en train de flamber
et ça ça pose un problème pour le budget
des ménages parce que aujourd'hui
imaginer un ménage qui doit changer
d'appartement parce qu'il a des enfin un
nouvel enfant vient d'arriver dans le
foyer ou tout simplement parce que le
travail impose le changement
si vous voulez d'appartement ou de
maison et bien à ce moment-là ce ménage
va être amené à surpayer l'acquisition
d'une maison ou d'un appartement est
donc évidemment ça va peser lourdement
sur le budget des ménages
en conclusion jacques on aurait donc non
pas une inflation mais plaisir oui tout
à fait on est en réalité
confronté à deux inflation qui sont
distinctes et la véritable question
c'est de savoir est ce qu'elle ne
pourrait pas se combiner en un seul
mouvement inflationnistes on a d'un côté
l'inflation qui vient je dirais de
facteurs réels
donc c'est le déséquilibre entre la
demande et le redémarrage de la
production leur démarrage de l'offre bon
mais ça on voit bien que ça ne va pas
durer éternellement
c'est une question qui sera réglé un
pire à la fin 2022
bon il ya le problème aussi des coûts de
transport de la désorganisation mais
tous ces problèmes sont normalement
appelées à se régler d'ici un an à 18
mois
et puis il ya un autre problème c'est le
problème justement des conséquence de
l'injection de monnaie dans les
économies qui fait flamber les actifs
patrimoniaux qui fait flamber les prix
du logement au point d'ailleurs que la
banque centrale européenne réfléchit à
intégrer les prix du logement dans son
indice des prix et ça ça pose évidemment
un problème très important pour le
laisser voler pour le budget des ménages
alors la question que l'on doit se poser
c'est est-ce que ces deux inflation
resteront séparés et à ce moment là il y
aura pas de véritable problème puisque
on voit bien que l'inflation réelle qui
est pour l'instant la plus forte à qui
est celle qui pour l'instant portes
d'une certaine manière
'l'indice des prix on voit bien qu'elle
va s'essouffler fin enfin disons début
2022 voire fin 2022 ou bien est-ce que
cette inflation va se combiner avec
l'inflation monétaire qui pour l'instant
ne touche que les actifs patrimoniaux et
dans ce cas là elle pourrait
activement s'inscrit dans la durée à
suivre donc dans les mois qui viennent
jacques mercier l aspect emmanuel macron
va participer au sommet du g5 c'est
lille va définir un calendrier pour le
retrait des troupes françaises de
l'opération barkan le président français
va également évoqué la nouvelle
stratégie qui s'appuie sur une
coopération occidental pour former les
armées locales
un défi qui s'annonce déjà bien
difficile à remporter les explications
de katia technique la force barkan est
sur le départ un contingent de 5100
sommes présents sur le terrain au sahel
le président français va participer au
sommet du g 500 un rendez-vous en
visioconférence avec les chefs d'état de
mauritanie mali niger burkina faso au
tchad
il va donc préciser un calendrier de
retrait pour les toutes françaises et
définir la composition de l'opération
qui va remplacer marc khanne takouba il
avait esquissé les contours de cette
force composites dans son intervention
de juin l'état final recherché c'est
évidemment de réduire nos emprises
multiples de réduire la logique
opérations extérieures de garder deux
piliers un pilier lutte contre le
terrorisme avec des forces spéciales
structuré autour de takouba avec
évidemment là dessus une forte
composante française avec encore
plusieurs centaines de soldats et des
forces africaines européennes
internationales à nos côtés cette
opération barkan au fil du temps est
devenu très critique et elle a pris la
relève en 2014 de l'opération serval
initié par françois hollande en 2013
l'ancien président français avait alors
répondu à l'appel au secours du chef
d'état malien par intérim
dioncounda traoré ce dernier était
dépassée par les troubles occasionnés
par les groupes indépendantistes touareg
et les groupuscules islamistes au nord
du pays
ces derniers ont été rapidement contenue
mais ils se sont ensuite éparpillés et
se sont mises à fourmiller bien au delà
du mali au niger et au burkina faso
la france est alors embourbé dans une
sorte de mission impossible face à des
milles
de kilomètres carrés de désert la
population locale prise en étau entre
les militaires nationaux alliés de
barkan et les chefs djihadistes qui
venait prendre le contrôle des villages
s'est alors mise à critiquer cette
opération une présence française en
lisait de moins en moins légitime est de
plus en plus contesté par les pays du
sahel
emmanuel macron veut tourner la page à
moins d'un an de la présidentielle
il compte profiter de l'impact d'un
retour des troupes à la maison
il en appelle un sursaut au mali pour
que le pays se saisissent lui-même de sa
sécurité et de son pays de moyens pour
son armée emmanuel macron a même
interrompu brièvement la coopération
militaire à la suite du coup d'état de
mai depuis les patrouilles conjointes
ont repris au mali une manière
d'enclencher une nouvelle stratégie
après avoir frappé du poing sur la table
un redémarrage qui certainement inclut
des engagements côté malien est en tout
cas le conseil national de transition en
appelle à une coopération continue
peut-être demain si mal et continue de
sombrer
si le sénégal la mauritanie la guinée
qui risquent de tomber et tous ces pays
là sont des partenaires stratégiques de
la france
si aussi ici le mali dont six cette
digue est rompu cette digue malienne est
rompu si ce sera aussi une partie de
l'europe occidentale qui sera touché
même si la france retire ses troupes
emmanuel macron compte maintenant
convaincre ses partenaires occidentaux
qu'il faut s'investir
même si c'est d'une autre manière
parviendra-t-il avoir gain de cause
alors même qu'on le voit quitter le
territoire
si la france est moins parties prenantes
sera t'elle écouté par les pays du g5
celle des nations africaines en
difficulté en crise qui pourraient être
soulagées par des négociations avec des
jihadistes pour mettre fin aux guérillas
le soutien de la russie est également
recherché par certains pays du sahel et
qui va s'investir dans la force takouba
les partenariats et options restent
floues après le semi échec et
l'enlisement de barkan il reste très
difficile pour emmanuel macron de bâtir
la stratégie d'après pour venir en aide
au g5 sel et de continuer à assurer une
présence française en même temps sera
plus tout à fait là un des actes de
déstabilisation en irak c'est ce qu'a
dénoncé la france après une succession
d'attaqués contre des intérêts
américains mais aussi des bases de la
coalition internationale contre le
groupe terroriste des ch comme
l'aéroport derby
dans le kurdistan irakien à bagdad
l'ambassade américaine à elle a été visé
aujourd'hui par trois roquettes
pour le ministère français des affaires
étrangères il faut coopérer avec les
autorités irakiennes pour faire cesser
ces violences qualifiées d' inacceptable
par le quai d'orsay
la multiplication des attaques contre
les emprises diplomatiques est les bases
de la coalition internationale contre
des ch est inacceptable
face à ces actes de déstabilisation qui
portent atteinte à la sécurité de tous
les irakiens
la france rappelle son attachement à la
souveraineté de l'irak ainsi qu'à la
stabilité et de la région autonome du
kurdistan
la france appelle à une coopération
accrue avec les autorités irakiennes et
au renforcement des efforts de
coordination entre ces dernières pour
faire cesser ses attaques et traduire
leurs auteurs en justice
le président de la république algérienne
t bone a annoncé la composition d'un
nouveau gouvernement une équipe très
proche de l'ancienne avec la moitié des
anciens ministres reconduits
les précisions de notre correspondant au
maghreb s m shelly c'est un nouveau
gouvernement sans réelle surprise qu'ont
découvert les algériens presque un mois
après l'échéance législatives du 12 juin
marqué par un taux d'abstention de 77%
et une répression sans précédent du
principal mouvement contestataire le
irak de présidente et bouna a dévoilé la
composition de l'équipe gouvernementale
est seul ministère régalien a changé
sont ceux des affaires étrangères et de
la justice pour le reste c'est le statu
quo sur la nouvelle équipe composée de
34 membres dont quatre femmes seulement
17 ministres ont été reconduits dont
ceux de l'intérieur la santé ou encore
l'énergie
un immobilisme certains qui semble
cristalliser l'impasse politique dont
souffre le pays depuis le début du
soulèvement populaire du irak en 2019
ce nouveau gouvernement loin de répondre
aux aspirations du peuple algérien met
plutôt en exergue les ratés du pouvoir
en place
écoutez à ce propos l'analyse du
politologue da manha des le crime
si l'on se réfère à l'effet d'annoncé on
est en droit de se demander si ce sens
va pas être un simple remake maintenant
les spas situation et communes en scène
particulière où les enjeux sont
terribles sur le plan politique la
thérapie de provins même s'il est dans
une forme de la france par intermittence
entre l'expression les enjeux
économiques sans enfant terrible
les enjeux sécuritaires ce qui se passe
en libye ce dans le sahel etc
à tous ces éléments là peut-être qu'ils
vont probablement dans l'est une
incidence sur synergie qui va
s'installer le gouvernement adjoint est
aujourd'hui plus que déterminé à
poursuivre sa normalisation politique et
institutionnel tout en ignorant les
revendications de la rue plus de 300
personnes sont actuellement en prison
qu'ils soient en lien avec le irak ou
défenseurs des libertés individuelles
selon le comité national de libération
des détenus la nouvelle assemblée quant
à elle doit prendre ses fonctions ce
jeudi
dix ans après son indépendance le soudan
du sud ne parvient pas à construire un
état fort pour répondre aux besoins de
sa population le pays
ni confrontait une importante crise
économique et humanitaire
robin pu l la joie des premiers mois
d'indépendance a rapidement été remplacé
par les doutes et les crises le soudan
du sud est encore un pays économiquement
fragiles malgré des ressources
pétrolières importantes
le pays est exempte ruiné par cinq
années de guerre civile qui ont fait
près de 380 mille morts selon la banque
mondiale plus de 82% de la population
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté à jouba la
capitale les habitants ont perdu leur
optimisme j'avais l'espoir qu'un jour
nous serions une grande nation une
nation indépendante développé avec
beaucoup de ressources
est ce que nous vivons actuellement
c'est une crise économique
tout est très cher et il faut réussir à
vivre à jouba imaginer qu'un kilo de
viande coûte aujourd'hui 10 dollars
américains
c'est vraiment très cher pour nous qui
vivons avec moins d'un dollar par jour
ça va devenir encore pire l'alimentation
est en effet l'une des principales
préoccupations
malgré des terres fertiles l'agriculture
a été ravagée par les différents
conflits
les conditions climatiques de ces
dernières années ont également aggravé
une situation déjà critique près de 7,2
millions de personnes sont en situation
d'insécurité alimentaire une conjoncture
très préoccupante pour les dirigeants du
programme alimentaire mondial des
nations unies qui opèrent dans la région
en tant qu'organisation nous essayons de
nous rire 5,3 millions de personnes ici
au soudan du sud
c'est donc une des plus grande opération
au monde et bien sûr lorsque vous
regardez ce que cela signifie pour la
population nous nourrissons un nombre
très important de sud soudanais et nous
ne le ferions pas si la situation
n'était pas aussi grave
avec une économie particulièrement
vulnérable aux chocs climatiques
pétroliers ou encore au conflit
interethnique
les chantiers sont encore nombreux pour
le gouvernement du son
du sud en futures d'autant plus
incertain que les élections initialement
prévue en 2022
pour marquer la fin de la période de
transition ont été repoussées en 2023
dans le reste de l'actualité au
lendemain de l'assassinât du président
d'haïti quatre hommes sont actuellement
retranchés dans deux bâtiments est
encerclée par la police à port au prince
la capitale
ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir fait partie
du commando responsable de l'assassinât
de jouvenel moïse la nuit dernière à son
domicile
plus tôt dans la journée de payer
annoncé la mort de quatre mercenaires et
six autres ont été arrêtés l'un d'eux
serait américain et qui traverse une
grave crise politique et sécuritaire
depuis de nombreux mois maintenant le
président moïse était accusé par la
population d'inaction face à la
situation et d'avoir dépassé la date de
son mandat à la tête du pays françois
xavier lambert avec médiers ski fis
c'est en direct à la télévision que le
premier ministre par intérim d'haïti ce
annonce la nouvelle
le président haïtien jouvenel moïse a
été assassiné chez lui dans la nuit par
un groupe d'étrangers parlant espagnol
et anglais
claude joseph annonce également que la
femme du chef d'état a été blessée se
trouve à l'hôpital dans un état grave
il appelle la population au calme et
garantit que le maintien de l'ordre est
assurée
tout le monde car que sur internet
meetic
tout le monde quels que soient ses
tendances politiques
quel que soit son idéologie politique
tout le monde dans le pays est sous le
choc parce que tout simplement personne
n'attend n'espère anticipe des actes
barbares comme ceux commis sur le
président je venais le moïse
ça qui compte
son président
l'assassinât du président haïtien
aggrave encore un peu plus le chaos dans
lequel s'enfonce haïti depuis plusieurs
années depuis son élection en 2016
jovenet le moïse n'a pas amélioré la
situation d'un pays gangréné par
l'insécurité est miné par la corruption
depuis un an les manifestations se
multipliaient contre le chef d'état
haïtien qui gouvernait par décret qui
avait outrepassé la fin de son mandat
prévu en février 2021 la population
haïtienne se montre aujourd'hui inquiète
et condamne elle aussi cette attaque
meurtrière
c'est frustrant et ça m'énerve de voir
des coups de feu dans l'endroit où je
vis et ce n'était pas n'importe quels
coups de feu avec des armes lourdes pour
calmer la colère d'une population
impacté par les pénuries et une pauvreté
galopante
le dirigeant aura nommé pas loin de sept
premiers ministres le dernier en date
n'aura même pas eu le temps de prendre
ses fonctions jovenet le moïse n'aura
pas pu mettre en place non plus la vaste
réforme institutionnelle qui devait
renforcer les pouvoirs de l'exécutif
après un vote par référendum repoussée
pour cause de crise sanitaire
face à cette situation de plus en plus
dégradées la communauté internationale
avait appelé à la tenue d'élections
législatives et présidentielle
transparente d'ici la fin de l'année
c'est donc une nouvelle période
d'instabilité et d'incertitude qui
s'ouvre pour le pays
en réaction la république dominicaine a
ordonné la fermeture immédiate de sa
frontière avec haïti et c'est la fin de
cette émission prochain point complet
sur l'actualité de la journée avec
emilie goog h à 22h
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame 50 négociations
politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre 20 perd gros là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]